on April 15th 2011 I spent my 21st
birthday in jail this is that story
thankfully I can laugh at this story now
but there was some real serious
consequences that are still following me
to this day if you're turning 21 like
have fun but please please please be
smart here we go
so the student at the University of
Oklahoma and they are very strict about
drinking I mean the whole state of
Oklahoma is I'm not hating on Oklahoma I
loved Oklahoma I love going to school
there the state itself was beautiful and
I was turning 21 and I was stoked to
graduate from house parties to a bar
across not only was I turning 21 I was
turning 21 on a Friday which I thought
was totally awesome campus quarter
Thursday night birthday dinner and party
Friday night hanging out and playing
video games with friends the rest of the
weekend it's my 21st birthday I know I'm
gonna be a little bit irresponsible so I
at least wanted to do one responsible
thing that night I parked my car at my
buddy's place he lived a couple of
blocks from campus corner so that way we
could walk from his house party it up
and I could just crash on his couch that
night so the night of my birthday my
car's parked me my friends we shimmy
over to my favorite taco spot on campus
corner
Fuzzy's load our bellies full of dank
tacos some queso okay so when you think
about it
it's kind of weird that we celebrate our
21st birthday by seeing how much alcohol
is being consumed before blacking out
that's like turning 16 years old and
saying oh oh boy I get six cars and
speed 120 miles an hour down
cuz I got my license the plan of tacos
in case it was great it lasted me
through about three margaritas in a
couple of tequila shots at this point I
was starting to enter the brownout phase
which in Clarke's dictionary means the
moments leading up to inevitable
blackout so after the clock strikes
midnight nine officially 21 I get a call
from my sister which I don't remember
and she said I was very very very very
excited like Tom Cruise jumping on a
couch exciting midnight to 1:45 a.m. are
a little hazy but when I finally
reinterred my body I was peeing in a
parking lot peeing all in the parking
lot yours fuzzy is a taco place here's
my car here's Clark maybe a quarter mile
from his apartment hanging in the middle
of the parking lot
and I forgot to mention but uh this
doesn't wasn't like some random hidden
parking lot this was a church parking
lot
I am peeing in God's parking lot in my
head I'm in the clear about to finish
Malik
everything went pretty well and then I
see these tinges of blue and red out of
the corner of my eye and I heard a deep
booming voice you all right there buddy
[ __ ] yep that's the cops
so I'm pleading with them some sort of
mumbled gibberish tell him how it's my
21st birthday and how I did a really
responsible thing really son didn't
drive at least I didn't drive in the cop
car all the way through getting
processed through jail jail yep I was
booked into IRL jail not the drunk tank
we're talking Shawshank Redemption
orange is the new black oz level jail
and add icing to my birthday cake since
I was arrested early Friday morning I
wasn't gonna see a judge until Monday
which meant I wasn't just spending my
birthday in jail I was spending the
entire birthday weekend
in jail at the time I didn't really
register how badly I screwed up I didn't
think that when my phone would be
ringing nonstop that I was supposed to
work at the equipment cage on campus
there were classes that I would be
missing at some point late Thursday
night early Friday morning I must have
fallen asleep or blacked out or both I
woke up under a scratchy old blanket
metal bunk bed inside of a withering
grain jail cell and I was wearing what I
think you could best describe as traffic
cone orange like nurse scrubs and Crocs
this truly was president my heart starts
sinking into my chest [ __ ] suddenly he
is gravely like Josh Brolin sounding
voice from the other corner of the room
boarded princess sounds like you had fun
last night I have a cellmate of course I
have a cellmate so I turn my aching head
and I look at this dude leathery skin
like popcorn kernel yellow teeth like
sunken in cheeks is big bushy beard that
I'm pretty certain you could hide a
knife in great this is it
this is Jim I was locking your with my
cellmate no one ever pairs you in life
like what to talk to a cellmate about
who's your favorite character on Parks
and Rec what's your favorite sports team
how's the weather okay it's a quick
pause because this is a part of this
story that's disturbing it involves
animals and like if you've seen any of
the videos that I've been in you know
that little corgis and kitties little
piggies and any other thing that's cute
adorable and I really really really hate
this next part of this story so here we
go I decided to strike up a conversation
I asked um what are you in here for
he's don't same her please don't say
murder please don't say murder Oh cop
[ __ ] ago what my cellmate the guy that
I'm locked in this little box with is an
actual bestiality offender it hoped that
I was massively hung over because he
extended what I could actually say to
him was something along the lines of
gotcha so I rolled back on him back
stared up at the metal bunk bed and just
saying myself happy birthday happy
birthday several hours pass and lunch
finally came I lined up got my tray from
the correctional officer there's some
super stale cornbread this like nitty
goop that I don't even think a dog would
eat I'm like scanning around the room
I'm seeing these dudes with long
scraggly hair and their big scraggly
beards I look just like these dudes
hungover feeling like death I'm looking
like death what am I doing with my life
I could tell that it was kind of turning
tonight because a little sliver of light
that was coming through in each jail
cell was turning from milky white -
there's like deep rich purple another
correctional officer walks in and starts
listing off names Davis Johnson
McCaskill
the kaskell this good or bad
I followed the officer with hesitation
and then he told me that I was going to
be having a webcam session with the
judge holy [ __ ]
but you know III had to keep it cool
because you know prison I talked to the
judge and she said that what I did was
really really stupid and not something
to take lightly but also not something
to spend the entire weekend in jail for
and that I'd be released that night I
actually cried I cried in front of the
judge I was just so relieved and so
happy sorry my paperwork get my
belongings
get out of my god awful crocks and my
orange scrubs so I walk out of jail it's
like 7:00 p.m. but I'm still way too
nervous to turn on my phone because I
had a lot of missed calls all right get
to my car I Drive home I go to bed in my
room without a cell mate that's I spend
my 21st birthday in jail
[Music]
you